[Music]
this small three acre island is home to
one of the most cherished sea temples in
Bali Tana Lodge translates to land in
the sea in the Balinese language which
perfectly describes this rock formation
and the temple that sits atop it it can
be found along the southwest coast of
Bali and is one of seven ocean temples
each of which was built with an eye line
of the next tanah lot was built around
the 16th century to honor the sea
spirits it is believed that it is
protected by sea serpents the rock base
that the temple sits on has been
reconstructed over time as the original
rock had begun crumbling into the ocean
visitors are able to access the island
via foot during low tide
however non Balinese people are not
permitted to enter the temple
this is one of the MERS visited and
photographed temples in Bali and it is
especially busy at sunrise and sunset
although if you intend to visit don't
bring a date
it is believed there is a curse on
unmarried couples who visit the temple
their relationship is doomed but this
view might just be worth the risk
[Music]